hey what's up guys it's Marcus roundly
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
video this one's actually not an HD
tutorial like I would normally do but
this is a software video screen
recording to show you guys that there is
a new little thing that's come up that's
popped up on YouTube as you can see by
the title that YouTube is now censoring
comments meaning if you post like some
kind of curse word on the in the
comments section of the video YouTube
will censor it like it'll put these
little asterisks little stars you see
under the video so let me go to my
latest video which was the phishing
tutorial and go ahead and click on it
there are 32 comments here and if we go
down here look at this most of these
comments are all stars and that's
because if we go down to the first
comments that were left on this video as
you know people are making comments
saying you know thanks for the tutorial
and everything and then you go up and in
the video I mentioned that that I was
denied from YouTube partnership and then
recently after like as they you know
they watched the video they decided to
comment on it they said something bad
about YouTube that had curse words in it
and if you look at the I can find them
real quick here so yeah if you look at
those curse words if you look at them in
the comment section they all have stars
on them and then I posted a reply
comment saying wait a minute did YouTube
just censor that because I looked in my
email and my email says and my email
actually has the word in it like you can
see the word and then you go to youtube
to go to reply to it and you notice it's
all asterisks so I mean it's just kind
of weird that YouTube's been changing a
lot of things lately and you might know
you might have noticed that on July 9
today YouTube was down in the afternoon
for a good 10 to 15 minutes and I guess
this was implementing a new feature or
whatever you want to call it so again
you know see for yourself if you want to
leave
comment below this video telling you
what you think I know YouTube's made a
lot of changes in the past couple of
days really actually a couple of weeks
you know they're forcing a few things on
the users that may or may not be wanted
by the community they forced the the
YouTube channel 2.0 they forced a
censorship of course on all comments and
yes they're gonna start you know they've
been removing a ton of videos due to
copyright infringement and all that
stuff it's been really really hectic up
here on the side so if you you know if
you've had any thoughts about YouTube
censor in common so if you just want to
get your anger out and have it all
censor just put it down there you know
leave a comment and please favor this
and feature it on your channel share it
get the word out because this is you
know YouTube they've they really made a
lot of new changes in the past couple of
weeks that YouTube users should really
know about anyway this has been Marcus
Brownlee from mkbhd thank you for
watching this video just a little
screencast letting you guys know what's
up and as always I'll catch you guys
later with another video peace